intelligence officials tell cbs news
they believe a new recording from the
shadowy leader of isis
is authentic the video that surfaced
yesterday shows
abu bakr al-baghdadi is alive and well
and looking to expand the group's global
reach
now this is the first time we've seen
him in about five years charlie dagetto
was in syria last month when isis lost
its last territory
and has been studying the video charlie
good morning good morning to you norah
this video is all about abu bakr
al-baghdadi stepping out of the shadows
to show that he's still
calling the shots and rallying
supporters around the globe
the beard is a bit grayer aside from a
reddish
dye and he seems to have put on a few
pounds from his last public appearance
five long years ago in mosul when he
announced the creation of the so-called
caliphate
now we watched that all come to an end
last month in eastern syria and that
final isis
military defeat in bagooz and despite
all that death and destruction around
them
a lot of those isis families told us
they still supported baghdadi until the
very end
and would continue to do so as for his
whereabouts soldiers we are with think
he slipped into the syrian desert during
the final weeks of battle
most likely crossing over into iraq but
while baghdadi has lost all his
territory
the whole point of this video is to show
that isis remains a potent force
aiming to expand its reach across the
globe
john all right charlie dagetta in london
thank you charlie